ja das ist richtig jetzt ist wieder so
typisch sagen weil sich jeder mal
abgeschlossen sind
sie kommen zu einer solchen leuten an
bord wieder mit max und ich habe wieder
ein deutsch bevorzuge bessere leute und
zwar heißt es beim spielen 94 prozent
400 prozent von was auf jeden fall
bedeutet weniger wiederum stark leute
das mir sieht so aus wir was wir jetzt
machen werden leute wir haben ja zwei
tempel zwei stifte und ihr seht schon
die stehen jeweils kategorien zum
beispiel das gefällt kindern und das
erste was ich morgens mache und wie
gesagt das spiel als 490 prozent das
prinzip ist herauszufinden was 94
prozent aller menschen machen bzw
die antworten aus zu finden die 400
menschen auf dem gewissen frage wie zum
beispiel das gefällt kindern süßigkeiten
oder videos von grad
das wäre natürlich gut nämlich erneut
immer gibt einen süßigkeiten und videos
von krankhafter und videos von escada
hat man eigentlich viele punkte sodass
die spieler sind aber so leute wie
gesagt wir haben jetzt hätten die frage
nach 30 sekunden zeit seine
antwortmöglichkeiten aufzuschreiben und
danach überprüfen wir die nerven wer
besser raten kann was andere menschen
denken macht natürlich jeweils eine
strichliste leute gucken wir am ende des
videos die meisten punkte gehört hat wer
verliert muss den ganzen stabilo essen
nein
los gehts wieder als gewinntreiber ist
aufreißt kunden bis reggae über die
religion 3 2 1
die frage ist das gefällt kinder okay
aus gefell kindertreff auf uns nicht
dazu schreiben die zahl bei aber
naja ich hab jetzt schon vorbei
ich habe viele sachen aufgeschrieben 4
ja was ist deine erste sagte meine erste
sache ist süßigkeiten aber ich bin mir
geklaut auf jeden fall spielen
das halte ich auch dann habe ich
fernsehen ich auch der kabarettist
ebenfalls fernsehen hitze aber ist dass
die lobbys hilfs oder das ist ja jetzt
ist mir so typisch dann weiß ich jetzt
noch mal menschen nicht gesehen nicht
abgeschlossen
süßigkeiten gehe ich ein spiel hat er
mir erzählt also ich viele eingegeben
hat mag er angeblich noch ein fernseh
und euro 3 prozent weiter hinten als
makaber ist dabei es gibt also dass
gutachter freunde bild gespannt denn da
ist dabei dann hast du vier und drei
ohrringe leute freute sich dabei bin ich
hier freunde ein geber achtmal auf die
texteingabe da unten dann vibriert das
heißt es nicht dabei ist die zweite
kategorie leute und die kategorie heißt
das erste was ich morgens mache da ich
jetzt wahrheitsgemäß antworten nämlich
nicht das was die anderen machen
da kann ich schon bisschen mehr
das war für mich hat alten zugeschrieben
44 ich habe diesmal fünf geschrieben das
ist vielleicht was ist dein erstes
kaffeetrinken kinder oder nein
definitiv meine erste sache ist heute
okay ich habe aufs klo gehen
ausgetrieben
es gibt nämlich keine punkte was und
nach wieder boden zu machen keine
talente dann habe ich ja sehr
zähneputzen verdammt habe ich nicht aufs
klo geht es war das duschen frühstücken
ok körper jede nicht so beim grad
du bist ein punkt haben für was kann ich
gebe einfach mal kaffee kaffee gibt
einfach mal eine nette leute noch
dasselbe boxweltmeister dann aber
auffassung die wohl aber ehrlich gesagt
stimmt das schon leute gesagt dass das
was mein gott handys nicht dabei so eine
lüge das allererste was am set dann gebe
ich jetzt mal 10
jawoll vegan da ist dann auch nur aus
dass mir sagen ich hab nichts wird apa
ich habe noch drei weiter kann ich jetzt
gehen wieder davonziehen und zwar gehe
ich mal ein bisschen ruhiger sagt ich
gebe jetzt noch mal ein waschen wenn ich
bewundere vorgekommen neben war alles
gesehen was bei duschen dabei dann habe
ich als beste kommt noch anziehen
jawohl ja
okay leute und jetzt am ende jedes
levels gibt's einen bildschirm stelle
ein bild gezeigt und du musst einfach
dazu scheint was leute zu diesem bild
sagen oder denken ach was zugleich die
kunden läuft und hier ist das bild doch
so ist es ihr gut sagt
okay okay dann auch mal raus was mit
deiner ersten sachen wein habe ich auch
bei einer alkohol beim glas sollte das
gericht ihn betrunken trinken dann habe
ich erwachsen war es ein achtjähriges
kind das verwachsen ist gegeben als
alias seinen wein und er weiß dass nadja
garantiert weißt ja wohl beide 42
prozent geführt beide einen entspannten
punkten gebe ich als nächstes ein glas
ist dabei auch ein trinken trinken ist
dabei alkohol alkohol
jawohl das ist noch ein separater punkt
warum könnt nicht dabei die ganz
erwachsen dabei ist springt aus dem
fenster und seinem glauben treu
naja trauben das sind beträgt nicht
traube im glas wasser das bringt man mit
ägypten in verbindung mit der liga geht
wie festgeschrieben insgesamt sieben und
sagt mein erster fahrer auf mein zweites
kleopatra ich wollte dass das dass
tutanchamun schreiben und diese ein
schüler der im geschichtsunterricht mit
seinem business entwickelt toutant ja
man kann dem fahrer euro opera mini 2
40% kleopatra es ist da war er bislang
ich glaube es nicht dabei mein nächster
punkt ist dann einfach sand ich habe
gesagt ich bin realist ich nehme als
nächstes klar
drei tage steht alles darüber jetzt im
finale stand bei mir 18 bei mir 18 du
auch lackiert wird dann bitte so ist
aber der schritt dass aktivierte die
finger zu schauen so weit bis zum
nächsten video leute ihr könnt hier
gerade im fall beantworten aber das
video gefallen hat wir werten diese
mobbing erbeuten dass wir den deal so zu
machen gerade danke max dabei sind
schmeckt selten ja ok